we addressed earlier in the program the
rules for the virtual off-season program
we raised the question of whether or not
dak prescott would be participating
because there was a strong belief he
would not be showing up for the real
off-season program without a long-term
contract from the cowboys that's his
leverage for now saying i'm not going to
show up for anything until you pay me
chris i am told that dak prescott
without a long-term contract from the
cowboys will not
be participating in the virtual
off-season program so even though all he
has to do is stay at home even though
it's only four hours a day even though
they're trying to get mike mccarthy and
new coaching staff or adjusted coaching
staff up to speed with the players and
hey no starting quarterback will be
involved in the virtual offseason
program absent the contract that doc
prescott believes he deserves from the
cowboys
wow i mean that that's big news
you know i'm not saying i'm shocked but
i wasn't sure which way he would go here
like we talked about earlier in the show
i thought maybe he would get involved in
these some of these meetings just to get
indoctrinated into the offense and maybe
some of the new terminology and ideas
but he's driving a hard bargain and he i
mean
to me it's unbelievable really mike you
know i i know that i wish dallas would
have sweetened that last contract offer
that we heard about where they gave him
a little less guaranteed money than
carson wentz all right i mean that's i
look at that but i mean what does he
really want out there on the market i'm
just really intrigued about what he's
asking for
but he can't get to the market that's
the thing
and here's the reality you're saying
he's driving a hard bargain with the
cowboys the cowboys have taken full
advantage of every rule under the cba
that benefits them as it relates to
dak prescott once he had his third year
in they didn't come to him and say this
is a joke that you're only going to make
4 million or 2 million excuse me next
year in the fourth year of the contract
we're going to get you taken care of now
before you have to go through another
season where you could get injured you
can have your performance dip we're
going to pay you now we think you
deserve it we think you've earned it
they didn't do any of that they squatted
on him through his entire rookie
contract and then they used the
franchise tag to keep him off of the
open market i mean ultimately we're
we're so desensitized to the franchise
tag the franchise tag is the device used
by the teams to prevent the player from
finding out what he's really worth like
hey cowboys if you're confident if
you're confident you're gonna pay him
let him go out on the market and see
what's out there but they refuse to do
it so he can his rights are under the
cba to refuse to participate in the
offseason program and i support it
i do too i got no problem with that i'm
just you know and i i misspoke by saying
i know we can't get to the open market
i'm just interested in what he's asking
for what's the number that is going to
satisfy him and his team right now uh to
to make this go you know where is it do
you have any inkling of what that might
be is he look what is it more
more more uh i mean i've heard you know
we've seen the number 35 and that's 35
from scratch not 35 new money because
there's no new money it's a new contract
and it's going to be 35 million dollars
per year from the moment he signs it if
that's what he can get
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports